hello hi how you doing off Lawrence
Hillsboro you doing right I called in
okay I was driving and there was a car
that came like on the other side and I
veered and then
I fucking
I
oh
man my other Tire like clipped and okay
all right where you come from
tonight uh my friend's house your
friend's house yeah in Hillsboro in
Hillsboro yeah okay you want my
um my sh yeah uh what do you want this
your license right now license hands up
license right now let me give you
a I have my friend coming to pick me up
because obviously I'm not going to be
able to okay you come from your your
friend's house hold on can put that on
right
back
10 yeah give me one more give me light
give me light let's have another un
you want
start one more what is
this what is this that you don't need
that that's fine you and then what else
do you need my license
license I'm sorry can I turn the light
on yeah go ahead I'm sorry 69
as
103 can can you start also I'm just so
mad because I just got new tires yeah
just for the tire
changer and all my tires going to be as
of right now just the tire change all my
tires are going to
be I'm not going to be able to get this
out I I need I need to get out for I'll
try I'm sorry try I'll try to get out
let me just do it one more time I
[Music]
try there we go
okay that's like that new ID that do not
yeah not for real okay wonder what is
just uh just I don't know what real idea
is but just uh oh you don't even know
yet I don't know just roll your window I
got it and I was like it says not for
real ID and I was like just just roll
your window up give that to no yeah you
can just roll your window up okay I was
like that's not
even
okay um my friend is coming to friend is
coming to pick you up yeah because
you're obviously this can't yeah I can't
drive yeah yeah yeah okay um so there
was like hard that was coming M on the
other side and so veed and then I went
on the um like the you know and then I
went over and then my tire just blew out
and then I reared over on
the and then I was and I I didn't know
what it was cuz I've never had that
happen before and it was like and and
then I stopped and then I pulled out or
I so I'm sorry I stopped I got out okay
and I was like oh shit that sucks all
and then I got back in and I was like
let me like pull up like can I pull up
every real quick have you had anything
to drink no no no I was like can I just
would you have your friend's house did
you have anything to drink there no no
no no okay just real quick I want you to
say the alphabet from letter C to the
letter O you don't need to put your seat
belt on so letter C to letter O without
singing
it c o c o y c d
e f
o a b c d e f o g h i j k
l okay uh what's your highest level of
education and a bachelor's degree
bachelor's degree okay yeah I want you
to count from letter from the number
75 just one second count from from the
number 75 to
backwards 75 to 56 back backwards come
on Sir
74 there's my partners you can go
P that his name Paul sorry I just PA but
75 75 to 56 without without
backwards like 75 40 uh
74 73 72 71 70 69
60 69 68 67
65 I'm sorry
6 60
59 58
[Music]
55 4 okay all all right step out for
me y we're going to step right over here
no you can leave your car
on all right we're going to step right
over the front of car over
here what happened to the car right
there on the inside I'm sorry it's okay
just come over
here yeah it's all right just stay stay
here Abby I'm telling you I okay there
was someone who came in all right why
don't you stand right stand right in
front of your car stand right here where
my light is stand right where my light
is okay all right do you have anything
wrong with your eyes no no okay no not
you it's okay sorry I just want to say
okay all oh no don't look don't look at
that look at my finger okay on you stand
still look at my finger all right want
you keep your head still and move your
eyes and your eyes only okay sorry can I
see the moon for a second s
okay just follow your eyes your eyes
only keep your head still
okay don't move your head oh I'm
sorry you got to look at it got look got
to look at my
hand
I I blinked it's okay you can blink not
problem no I
can't don't move your
head you got to look at my finger you're
not looking at it you got to look you
got to look at it okay follow it keep
your eyes on my
finger I's looking at your eyes got look
at my
finger don't move your
head you simple test all right I know
simple test the test okay you got to
look at the finger one more
time
all right we're not done yet we're not
done yet I'm sorry come back I've never
been pulled out of my car and I know
this fucking best it's so stupid no no
I'm all right I just I'm I'm all right
I'm upset we're almost done we're almost
done okay all right we're going to get
back to this body cam in a second but I
want to take a minute to talk about
something else that happens all the time
workplace injuries if you get hurt at
your job whether it's a a slip and fall
a mechanical failure negligence of your
co-workers something hits you you're
going to need a trusted law firm in your
corner enter Pon Le hockey Giordano a
firm that is a heavyweight in the
industry that wins all different kinds
of injury cases yes workplace but also
accidents Social Security Disability
injuries they have a track record of
recovering over $1 billion dollar for
their clients and they have won over a
100,000 cases they have 250 years of
combined exper experience how amazing is
that so you can check out ponle hocky
Giordano at ponle hockey.com
ELC bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body no I'm
upset okay where are you coming from
tonight come back here
where were you coming from
tonight I'm coming from my friend's
house where's that at sure right right
up the road the road uh do you did you
uh hit anything or no she said she went
off the road there was a car coming she
went to or something okay I'm sorry all
right no I just want to hear what you
said not what you said to your officer
okay something I I I didn't you didn't
hit anything no I I was there was like a
car coming there was a car coming on
this side and they were coming in my
lane and I I just listen it's okay I
just wanted to make sure I don't no it's
fine okay thank you I'm already out
already out of my car I I there was a
car coming on this side and I veed mhm
and they hit
the you know the uhhuh and I went off on
this side and I we got we got one more
test got all right now next test I'm
freezing I am cold too I am cold too
yeah you have like a the quicker we get
this done the quicker get warm okay you
know what I mean stay right there right
there okay I want you to imagine there's
a straight line in front of you okay I
want you to put your left foot on the
line put your right foot in front of it
touching heel the
toe I'm sorry left foot on the line
Right Foot In Front touching heel the
toe hands down your side this is my left
yeah left foot plant it wherever you are
plant it got it right foot in front heel
the
toe just like I am right here okay want
your hands down your side
yeah okay yeah hands down to your
side right foot in front of your left
hands down to your side I want you to
get in that get in that position right
now left foot my side left foot PL or
right foot in
front
Okay once you just stand just like that
okay on you try to hold that position
okay do you have anything wrong with
your leg legs that'll affect your
ability to
walk but can you walk in a straight
line no okay all right you have any
injuries or anything like that I teach
gymnastics you teach gymnastics okay so
so I'm like kind ofur it's okay all
right so feet together just like that
okay I'm going to devastate test for you
I do not want you to begin until until I
tell you can you get back in that
position for me right foot in front of
your left right foot in front of your
Left Right Foot Right Foot in front of
my your left to tell I want you to stay
in that position until I tell you to
move okay you understand that's my
friend that's your friend yeah okay you
want to tell them to I want to tell no
no no I'm fucking freezing I I am cold
too the quicker we get this done okay I
just stay right there what do you want
to do do you want right foot in front of
your left right foot in front of your
left just stay in there that's all I
want you to do right
now right front wherever he wants you
right right there okay AB we go right
foot in front of your left heel hands
down your side
right foot in front of your left hands
down to your side right foot in front of
my left I want you to stay like that
stay like that until I tell you to move
okay there a walk and turn turn I I'm
cold tooold this test you're going to
take nine steps nine steps forward I I
get what you're saying with the nine
steps okay I I have I have to explain it
then demonstrate it okay I I know I know
okay so you going to take nine steps
Heel To Toe forward on the ninth step
you're going to take a series of small
steps and you're going to turn around
take n steps back okay I'm going to
demonstrate a test for you are you are
you watching I yeah okay so it's one two
three four five 6 7 8 nine when you get
to the nin step you do nine I'm not
going to do nine no let me see your nine
no I'm not going to do nine okay okay
you're on your ninth step you're going
to keep that front foot planted you
going take a series of small steps and
turn around come back one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
nine okay I did three you're going to do
nine okay why are you doing the test I
want you to look look down your feet I
want to hands down your side okay I'm
going to count out loud okay MH all
right you can begin when you're ready
okay one two three oh yeah five
six
okay 2 3 4 5
okay we take one more test come over
here for me one more
test stand right over here stand right
over here I'm really cold too I
have it's it's not warm okay it's not
warm okay okay with the ls go okay feet
together hands down your side okay want
you stand just like that okay when I
tell you to when I tell you to you're
going to lift the foot of your choice
off the ground 6 in point your toe it
cannot allowed okay until I tell you to
stop okay if you uh put your foot down
you pick it back up put it back up um
put it back bring it back up and
continue count I'm going to demonstrate
a test for you okay like this 1 1,000 2
1,000 3 1,000 4 1,000 5 1,000 6 1,000
until you tell you to stop okay again if
you pick if you put your foot down pick
back up continue counting
okay one
second okay you begin when you're
ready
what do you want to do stopping what do
you want to do are you going to continue
or you going to stop the test now St to
you you want to do okay if you're not
going to continue then turn around turn
around turn around turn around
he right now you're putting place under
arrest we drinking
driving wait wait this one this one yep
I got it
see stay right there for 450
back to my
car you unlock the door for
me right you got anything on you knives
anything like that
no back my hand oh wait wait one one
second one second one second one
second okay
cool have a seat in there easier you sit
down first your feet in
go can I yep
he what do you need out of your car
purse and cell phone Christ purse and
cell
phone
sorry oh
man watch out for that
front yeah I'm I'm not going
thatwhere
got uh back here open
close the con CL all right um where is
her
cellone oh and there's a
hole it's closed
[Music]
okay
okay okay let try to find our cell
phone maybe maybe have go can I ask you
the dumbest thing what can you just push
the hair out of my face push the hair to
your face see
this it's okay where's your where's your
cell phone one more one more one more
where's your cell phone I don't know you
don't know I was trying to call it when
I got in that in that accident okay you
called so I know but I think I I think
that I called because I I hit the
emergency button on the like top on your
uh on your car okay I don't know where
my cell phone is don't know where your
cell phone okay I didn't see in your car
but I can I don't know where it is it
might be in my I'm serious okay I was
like where is it I I didn't see your car
when I got in this accident I didn't
know who to call okay and and then I hit
the button okay all
right all right I got everything else to
the course so I'll follow
you
10y
10 we transporting one female got to
headquarters starting mileage
52.9 see one F headquarters 332
where
okay I'm
to well all the the the debris might
start
there
yeah okay all right
yep okay
yeah